cam released today and jeff hall of the
athletic back here on the rich eisen
show to help walk us through all this
how are you jeff
hey how are we doing so what happened
today
well they released cam newton yes sir
that's the head the bigger story here is
that you know i've said it over and over
again i've written it quite a few times
especially over the last couple weeks
mac jones was the better quarterback
throughout the vast majority of the past
month and bill belichick
finally came out and confirmed it and i
think this is a surprise
because
of the way that you know we the way that
we were looking things we in the media
we had to go by what we were seeing and
we had to see or what we had been seeing
was cam newton lead off every single
period in practice he led off all three
preseason games
but
you know i i was speaking to a couple
people just yesterday who said you know
what you might actually want to pump the
brakes on that narrative because
look at what mac jones did last week in
the joint practices with the giants he
went 35 of 40 in the first practice the
second one he got one drive
against their starting defense and he
went 10 of 19 because of three maybe
four drops but still led the offense
into the end zone because of two uh
completions on fourth down two third
down conversions you know he continued
to handle bouts of adversity and the way
that belichick views these joint
practices is actually it's exceeding
what his viewpoint of the preseason you
can control the personnel packages
you're you're lining up against because
belichick was collaborating with joe
judge the night the night before these
workouts and
because of all that it was like yeah you
know what you know these people were
saying we understand what the optics are
we understand that cam newton's been the
guy that who's been leading the way in
these rotations but it's not out of the
realm of possibility that if mac jones
has significantly been better than
newton throughout the past month the
belichick could go in that direction now
i don't i can't sit here and say i was
going to put money on that at 9 00 a.m
this morning but that's what belichick
ultimately decided and it's surprising
on the surface when you look at it in
totality you know the writing had sort
of been on the wall here
well that's in terms of the writing on
the wall and then the headline of cam
newton released jeff howell of the
athletic year on the rich eisen show the
way that it went down belichick saying
earlier today when asked about cam
newton's progress and the status of
everything saying that he started off at
a higher you know bar and at a higher
mark than last year because this is his
second year in and he said that he's
heading in the right direction
and um then the release happens is it
possible that
that uh bill told him that he's number
two on the depth chart
and cam then asked for his release is
that possible that that's how this went
down tonight jeff
i can't yet rule that out i've been
trying to figure that out for the last
couple hours and just haven't gotten any
answers there so it's certainly possible
but
you know that's that's something that
the coaches have said about cam newton
over the last several months that he's
you know advanced in comparison to where
he was a year ago and i certainly see
all that uh on the other side of that
coin i i meticulously chart every single
throw in these practices seven on sevens
and eleven on eleven so all these team
drills
and from last camp to this camp
newton's completion percentages down is
adjusted accuracy rate which factors in
drops has declined and his interceptions
have gone up despite less throws
so
you know there's the one factor that you
can't really compare last year's defense
that he was practicing against wasn't
nearly as good as this year's defense
but
you know just going by what we're seeing
yeah i mean there were
just the inaccuracy issues the cam
newton had last season you know those
hadn't completely disappeared yet i mean
yeah he looked like he might have had a
little more zip on the ball than a year
ago but he was still missing some throws
and
i think it's just
i understand you know mentally he had a
better grasp of the offense but again
there there were just some some missed
balls and when you've constructed this
passing game to attack the middle of the
field with hunter henry and johnny smith
and then slot receivers jacoby myers and
kendrick bourne those guys have to be
hit in the hands in order to not break
stride and to get some yards after the
catch and it's harder for a guy like
newton to fit it into those windows and
that's one of mack jones greatest
strengths and that's something that we
saw consistently all summer long jeff
howe the athletic here on the rich eisen
show the evaluation of both did it
involve
what happened last week where cam missed
five days due to what they was termed as
a miscommunication that appears his
vaccination status
led to uh him
having to test
um negative longer than somebody who
appears to be vaccinated
um is that at all possible that this
this was part of the evaluation of cam
in any way absolutely absolutely there
was
i can tell you with with a high degree
of certainty there was some frustration
last week uh from a lot of people in the
organization or enough i shouldn't say a
lot enough people in the organization
that it was a factor
and at minimum you know take that
frustration aside you know whether it
was a misunderstanding or whatever you
know this situation happened because cam
newton isn't vaccinated and
even if it was some frustration that was
going to taper off over the course of
the week you know this is still
something that had to at minimum
force bill belichick to have meetings
with his coaching staff to say all right
what's plan b because they could show up
at any point during the season and lose
their quarterback for that week's game
even if it was as early as monday of
that happening you know cam newton bill
belichick's policy for as long as i've
covered the team going back to 09 has
been if you miss three consecutive
practices you're not playing in that
week's game
so if if you missed the whole week
you're out sunday and that could happen
at any point for any reason and just
look at it you know the same exact day
the bills lost uh what a few players
because they were close contacts and
they were unvaccinated so it's not even
like you know cam newton could do all
the right things and he could quarantine
himself and all that stuff but if you
show up to the facility one day and all
of a sudden you've got a trainer who's
covered positive and you were in that
room or whatever equipment manager
anybody
all of a sudden you're starting
quarterbacks gone
so
that was something that had to factor
into the the equation
last one for you jeff howe of the
athletic um i guess lost amongst the
that headline that cam newton's released
is the fact that stefan gilmore
was placed on the physically unable to
perform list meaning the first six games
of the patriot season at the very
minimum will be without one of the top
players in the game what's up with that
jeff
yeah i it's funny because you say it's
sort of lost in the headlines there i
woke up this morning thinking gilmore's
status whether it was remaining on pup
or otherwise was going to be the biggest
story of the day so
that was that was certainly a big
development because you know he told
josina anderson i think last month now
at this point that he would be ready for
training camp if he needed to be and you
know training camp is is long gone at
this point and
you have to look at this as a hold in
situation and i have not heard of any
really any real developments in terms of
the contract status and
if you're gilmore you know you want the
money you want the raise like i
understand that if you're the patriots
you have to say well you know what part
of the reason why you want the raise is
because they continue to accelerate
bonus money over the last couple seasons
and they gave him you know he the chance
to earn more money in previous seasons
now of course that all comes back to the
end and
and rob gronkowski had a similar
situation but like two big examples and
i'll start with tom brady you know i get
it it's impossible to compare anybody to
tom brady but tom brady wanted a raise
in 2019 he was on the field he got his
raise august 4. rob gronkowski in 2018
wanted a raise in the last year of his
deal he was on the field he got it
august 30th stefan gilmore wants the
raise and the patriots to their right
you know they wanted to see stefan
gilmore hit the field and he hasn't done
that so
it's all i can do right here because
both sides have been so quiet with this
storyline all i can do is tell you what
i've been seeing and
if the patriots have not seen gilmore
hit the field for these practices you
know they have the right to be reluctant
to to give him a ton of money going into
the season so at this point it has it's
been the one of the more surprising
developments i never imagined it was
going to drag out this far into the
process and now it's going to go even
further because he's going to be on the
pup list for a minimum of six weeks so
let's just assume it is a hold in where
he's just like you know hey i'm showing
up but i'm not playing practicing this
and that the other thing what is that
what does this do for the patriot i mean
what what what what's the move to just
throw them on pup for the patriots just
to say okay you're hurt that's it you're
out for six weeks and
what does that accomplish i don't know i
i think it's just a hardline stance it's
a hardline negotiating stance i think i
mean again like until somebody is a
little more vocal about this process all
i can do is sort of read between the
lines
and
i mean you look at i don't know i guess
logan mankins was a hold out midway
through the season back in 2010 he
eventually got his money but he was also
coming off his rookie deal he was a lot
earlier in his career
i mean this is this is tough i don't
think anybody wins with this scenario
because stefan gilmore i mean a lot of
people kind of got on him last year
about his season right like stefan
gilmore was one of three defensive backs
to win defensive player of the year over
the last quarter century
like what he did in 2019 was absurd you
have to play at an absurdly high level
to win that award as a cornerback so he
wasn't going to be the same player but i
think a lot of people confused not being
the same player with being bad like
stephon gilmore was still probably one
of the three best cornerbacks at worst
in the nfl last year taking him off the
field does not help the patriots and
they're going to have jc jackson step
into that number one role jc jackson
last year in my opinion was the best
number coupe number two cornerback in
the league uh when he was the number one
without gilmore he had a roller coaster
ride and he had some rough out he had
some rough games when quarterbacks just
were not afraid to throw his way uh we
know how good he is playing the ball in
the air but he's gonna get a chance to
go out and prove that he can be a number
one cornerback either way he's gonna get
like just a boatload of money next
off-season free agency but then you know
number two you got jalen mills and
look jalen mills is a nice guy he
practices hard he does a lot of things
the right way he's not stefan gilmore
there's a natural drop-off in talent
from gilmore to anybody but jalen mills
is going to be their number two guy and
jon jones is a really good slot
cornerback he's dealt with some injuries
this offseason but you know he should be
ready for for week one i would assume
and uh you know i guess the the other
fallout is this possibly buys enough
time for john williams to make the
roster as their backup boundary
cornerback jeff howe thank you for the
time what a day what a day we'll catch
up down the line appreciate it all right
thanks rich jeff fowler the athletic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here